Jousting is the official sport of the US state
of Maryland.
35 years after leaving school, the majority
of people can still identify 90% of their
classmates.
Studies suggest that using sarcasm can significantly
improve your I.Q.
Fifteen percent of the air you breathe in
a subway station is human skin.
Undertakers have found that human bodies do
not decompose as quickly as they used to.
They believe the reason is because the modern
diet contains so many preservatives that they
delay decomposition after death.
Michael Jordan earns more money from Nike
every year than all of the Nike factory workers
in Malaysia combined.
There are more lifeforms living on your skin
than there are people on the planet.
In the 1960s, the CIA attempted to spy on
Russian embassies and the Kremlin by turning
cats into listening devices.
The program, called Acoustic Kitty, involved
surgically implanting batteries, microphones
and antennae inside cats.
An ostrich's eye is bigger than its brain.
In the 1800s feeding lobster to prisoners
was considered a "cruel and unusual punishment,
like making people eat rats."
A hummingbird weighs less than a penny.
There are only two beret factories remaining
in France.
There's an 80% chance that if you're 16 or
older, you've already met the person you'll
marry.
If the Simpsons aged at a normal rate Bart
would now be older than Marge was in the first
series.
Most antibiotics are made from bacteria.
You're more likely to become the president
of the United States than to win the lottery.